Оксана Барановська з Одеси разом із сином Владом втекли від війни Росії проти України до Німеччини.
Їх прихистила пара пенсіонерів у німецькому містечку Мьорс, що на захід від Дуйсбурга.
Оксані та Владу пощастило: у будинку родини Кюппербуш вони мають власні кімнати.
Допомагають німці також одягом та харчами.
Нам тут живеться безпечно, дуже затишно, вони дуже чуйні, допомогають в усьому.
В перший день ми отримали допомогу від країни.
Від початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії до України
чимало німців відкрили свої домівки для українських біженців.
Хтось пропонує кімнату на кілька ночей, хтось - приміщення для цілих родин на місяць-два.
Багато людей у Німеччині нині надають житло біженцям безплатно.
Ситуація змусила мене замислитися: якби мені довелося жити в чужій країні
й кинути все моє життя, якби в мене не було когось, хто міг би мені допомогти,
це було б жахливо. Я просто хочу допомогти людям якось упоратися
із цією жахливою ситуацією. Хоча би трішечки.
За даними ООН, понад три з половиною мільйони українських біженців виїхали за кордон.
З них у Німеччині зареєструвалися 280 тисяч.
У Берліні, щоправда, заявили, що реальні цифри можуть бути значно вищими,
адже обліку біженців на внутрішніх кордонах шенгенської зони немає.
Українці мають право вільно в’їздити до Німеччини за біометричними паспортами
й залишатися на території Шенгену без реєстрації до 90 днів.
Основний потік українців до Німеччини іде з Польщі -
туди від початку війни прибули понад 2 мільйони 300 тисяч українців.
Приватного житла для них уже не вистачає.
Більшості доводиться жити у центрах прийому біженців.
Їх, як ось тут, у Перемишлі, облаштовують у великих приміщеннях –
школах, спортзалах, готелях й навіть у монастирях.
Попри окремі заклики, у ЄС вирішили відмовитися від примусового розподілу українських біженців
із перевантажених країн, як Польща.
У Брюсселі обіцяють створити такі умови, що стимулювали б українців добровільно поїхати туди,
де ще немає великого напливу втікачів від війни.
Елла й Валерія з дітьми вимушені були виїхати зі Слов’янська.
Нині жінки у Перемишлі,
однак воліли би переїхати туди, де зможуть працювати, а їхні діти - вчитися.
Ми налаштовані на те, щоби поїхати кудись далі і шукати роботу, тому що з нами діти,
і їх треба прилаштувати, нагодувати, вдягнути, і навчатися теж..
Життя триває, сподіваємося…
Хотіли би поїхати до Німеччини, але кажуть,
там теж важко уже – і з робою, і з усім. Ми ще думаємо…
Тих, хто не може знайти житло у Німеччині самостійно або через волонтерів,
німецька влада тимчасово розміщує у спеціально облаштованих центрах прийому біженців.
Два найбільших розташовано у Коттбусі та у Берліні – у колишньому аеропорту "Теґель".
Наша запланована потужність - до 10 тисяч людей, але це лише план.
У разі потреби ми можемо збільшити кількість місць.
Але поки що ми не заповнили ці 10 тисяч місць.
Ми також пропонуємо місця для тих, хто хоче залишитися в Берліні -
вони можуть пожити тут кілька днів, коли приїдуть до міста, а потім їх розподілять деінде.
Берлін, Гамбург, Кельн, Ганновер, Мюнхен -
це головні пункти призначення, де намагаються осісти українські біженці.
Утім, у великих містах знайти окреме житло для українських родин значно важче, ніж у менших містах.
Тож, німецькі волонтери, які допомагають із прихистком,
радять українцям не гребувати пропозиціями селитися у провінційних містечках.
Адже там, окрім вільного житла, зазвичай можна швидше пройти всі бюрократичні процедури,
а також легше влитися у решту інфраструктури - школи, садочки, лікарні.
А підтримка місцевої громади навіть більша, ніж у великих містах.
Ми з усіх сил намагаємося створити додаткові місця. Гадаю від 50 до 100 місць
ми зможемо отримати у будь-якому разі, а далі буде видно.
Щоб стимулювати німців активніше допомагати українцям із поселенням у ФРН,
місцеві органи влади пропонують власникам житла субсидії.
Їхній розмір залежить від федеральної землі та міста.
Приміром, у Бонні - федеральна земля Північний Рейн-Вестфалія -
ліміт субсидії на квартиру для родини з двох людей становить близько 650 євро без комунальних платежів
їх влада покриває окремо.
Окрім даху над головою, реєстрація у Німеччині передбачає соціальну допомогу - 330-360 євро на дорослого
і від 250 до 320 євро на дитину залежно від віку.
Ці гроші не включають витрати на житло.
Діти мають право ходити у німецькі дитсадки й мусять відвідувати школи.
Крім того, уряд ФРН намагається спростити процедуру працевлаштування для українських біженців.
Однак попри обіцянки Берліна у небюрократичний спосіб приймати українців,
волонтери, які допомагають біженцям, скаржаться на недоліки німецької бюрократії:
багатогодинні черги на реєстрацію або кількатижневе очікування на оформлення соціальної допомоги.
Тим не менше такої готовності прихистити у себе українських біженців німці ще не знали.